a ukrainian military ambulance speeds
south towards slavyansk
evacuated civilians arrive in a van at a
ukrainian army checkpoint north east of
the city that the military won't allow
us to film
inside the vehicle are svetlana nelia
and nellie's 86 year old mother antonina
my husband is still in there at home i'm
very afraid for him
breaking down
every person in ukraine wants this war
to end says nelia and we can say that to
putin
stop this dreadful war
we're hearing a lot of shelling
as you can hear there possibly
that shelling coming from this direction
we're also hearing from that direction
about seven kilometers up that road is
the town of niman
now we are we know that russian forces
control the village very close to it we
also understand that most of the
civilians have left
and the military are telling us that
what the russians are trying to do
by attacking le mans is move closer to
the city of slovansk which is down this
road bloody tourniquets lie on the
ground close to the checkpoint
cut from the limbs of soldiers or
civilians injured the night before
a military ambulance arrives an injured
ukrainian soldier is helped to waiting
army medics who refuse to let us film
stop filming now he says
this crater is from what the ukrainian
army say was a russian rocket that
landed near another checkpoint on a
different road into slavyansk
it leads to the russian-controlled city
of isiam
the ukrainian army says it's holding
back at least a two if not three pronged
russian army advance
slavyansk along with neighbouring
cremators
only a 10 minute drive further south are
the two biggest cities in the donbass
region still under full ukrainian army
control
we drive into town the streets are
virtually empty
the people still here shop at the
occasional supermarket still open
many of the shelves are bare
of course we're afraid it's going to
happen the russians are pushing but we
hope the army can protect us and defend
the city we have a basement and that's
our only plan the main thing is that
we've sent our children away
a school was damaged when a russian bomb
landed close by but slavyansk has
escaped the heavy russian shelling
suffered by some towns in the donetsk
region
in the evening light a siren wails
warning those who remain to get inside
or underground
an almost deserted city
in the russian army's sites
charles stratford al jazeera slaviansk